if you're a gamer you probably use
discord to chat with friends
heck even if you're not a gamer you
probably use discord for something these
days
everyone uses discord but no one seems
to know exactly why discord is
completely destroying all the other chat
apps
and that's a shame because the founder
has one of the most interesting stories
i've ever heard in silicon valley his
name is jason citron
and he just became a billionaire with
discord's recent massive fundraise at a
7 billion
valuation but he didn't go to an ivy
league school and he never worked at a
big tech company
his path to success broke so many
silicon valley conventions
and every one of his strategies can be
directly copied if you're building a
startup yourself
like most successful founders jason is
super humble
in fact when he's asked about why
discord became so successful
he usually just says something simple
like this we were successful because our
product was like 10 times better and 10
times easier to use than the things that
came before it
so people have been switching and sure
building a great product is key to every
big startup success
but that doesn't really explain how
discord became so popular in the
beginning
what does jason know about growing a
startup that the rest of us don't
in many ways discord was late to the
party in communication software they
have plenty of competitors in the gaming
space
and slack offers similar functionality
to businesses
slack actually launched two years before
discord and now that salesforce acquired
them for 27 billion dollars
they should basically have limitless
resources to compete with discord but
slack seems to be falling behind
which raises the question how did
discord get so big
even though they launched two years
later than slack most social apps fail
completely but when they succeed and get
big
they tend to get really big and i think
discord is just getting started the
company recently passed 140 million
users
and has completely broken out of the
gaming niche where they got started
that type of growth is extremely hard to
come by in silicon valley and it really
shows that jason has a unique strategy
that differs from other startup founders
fortunately the way jason thinks about
growing a startup can be summarized in
just three key points
so let's dig in and try and understand
the mind of jason citron
jason's biggest strength is actually
something that many people might think
of as a weakness
he didn't have any impressive
qualifications before becoming an
entrepreneur
instead of studying engineering at mit
or getting a business degree from
harvard he attended a small school in
florida named
full sail university the school
specializes in media and arts
and isn't exactly known for churning out
successful startup founders
but jason knew he was interested in
video games and wholesale university
has a great program for game design
jason had already taught himself to
program at a young age
so when he got to college he was able to
focus on applying those skills to
something he loved
making video games after college he went
to work for a series of game studios
making iphone apps
and actually won some awards for mobile
game design after only two years working
for other people
jason quickly struck out on his own to
start a company even though he didn't
have an impressive resume
jason knew that he could build something
gamers would enjoy and that's jason's
first key advantage as an entrepreneur
he's a relentless builder people like to
think that in order to start a massive
company you either have to drop out of
college at a young age
or graduate from a top school but that's
simply not the case
let's look at some data to see what i'm
talking about here this data set was
compiled from over a hundred unicorn
companies
meaning these companies have been valued
at over a billion dollars
more than 35 of these unicorns were
founded by people with only a bachelor's
degree
and more founders had phds than were
dropouts
so the myth of the magical dropout
founder is just that a myth
clearly no matter what your educational
background is you can start a great
company
if you solve the right problem and
create a great product and clearly jason
knows that
and when it comes to attending
prestigious schools it might surprise
you to hear that just as many founders
of billion dollar companies
graduated from schools ranked in the top
10 as from schools with rankings that
didn't even crack the top 100. that's
the amazing thing about entrepreneurship
it doesn't require anyone's permission
getting a job at a top
tech company or working for a fancy
investment bank
is incredibly difficult if you don't
have the right school on your resume but
build something people want
and investors will look past your
background in a heartbeat having the
right credentials didn't matter to jason
he just wanted to make great games so he
started building
in 2008 he launched aurora faint which
was a puzzle game for iphones that had a
lot of really compelling role playing
elements
the game was fairly successful but
ultimately couldn't gain mass adoption
because of its high price point most
games at that time charged just one
dollar
so it was hard to get attention if you
charged more than that even worse for
jason
some developers had already figured out
how to sneakily offer in-app purchases
even though they weren't technically
allowed by apple jason had made a very
common mistake
by focusing too much on the core product
and leaving the business model as an
afterthought although it's incredibly
important to build something great you
can't put off thinking about how you'll
make money forever
besides a gaming company that goes out
of business isn't going to make any
gamers happy at all
so it's important to test your business
model a bit before you commit to it
fully with aurora faint struggling to
make money
and the company quickly running out of
cash jason decided to pivot the games
were underperforming
but the company had built some really
solid technology this was all before
apple had announced game center and it
was still a huge hassle for game
developers to add social features to
their games
having the ability to invite friends to
play games with you
could easily make a game go viral that's
what happened with words with friends
which was a social version of scrabble
for mobile devices
and draw something which applied the
same principles to pictionary
both apps grew organically because every
user would invite their friends to play
with them
and create a positive feedback loop
playing games with real friends online
is way more fun than playing against a
computer or a random person
so social features quickly became a
must-have for every mobile game but
building these social features
was often difficult and game developers
were more interested in improving their
core game mechanics
connecting to the user's address book
and linking up facebook accounts
was a very boring programming job that
no developer wanted to get stuck with
so those features often got left to the
last minute or put off entirely
jason's idea was to offer these social
features as a neatly packaged
software development kit that would make
adding these features quick
and easy there was only one problem
though his team hadn't actually built
any of that
and they didn't have the time to they
were only three weeks away from
bankruptcy and they couldn't afford to
spend all that time building this new
idea unless they were
absolutely sure that it would work but
that's where jason's second key
advantage comes in he's a master of
prototyping
even though jason didn't have time to
build a full-fledged product
he could still keep the company in
business if he proved that people wanted
his new social platform
so he set up a landing page for the
product which he called open
faint and outlined exactly what the
product could do
for game developers nothing had actually
been built yet but people visiting the
page
didn't know that they just saw a new
tool that could rid them of a tedious
task
let them launch faster and ideally make
their games go viral
in order to drive traffic to the new
site jason pitched the story to
techcrunch
and convinced a reporter to write an
explainer article about open faint
overnight they got 400 developers to
sign up which completely validated the
concept
jason and his team worked hard to build
open faint into a real product and get
it in the hands of game developers when
you're working on a new startup idea
it's extremely common to get sucked into
developing the actual product especially
if you're a software engineer and enjoy
coding i've certainly been in that
situation myself
what makes jason so unique as an
entrepreneur is that he can balance his
programming skills
with prototyping to validate his ideas
obviously the cash crunch motivated his
decision to launch the simple landing
page
it was really his only option but
validating your startup idea before you
start building
is always an option so be sure to use
prototyping effectively this strategy
worked out perfectly for jason
and open faint grew significantly the
growth was so strong in fact that just
two years after launching
a japanese company bought open faint for
over a hundred million dollars
this was an amazing windfall for a guy
who was just 26 years old
and didn't come from a wealthy family
but it wouldn't all be smooth sailing
from there
even though he had sold the company
jason originally planned to stay on
board at the company
and help them build an even better
version of open faint but the new
management
didn't see eye to eye with him so they
asked him to resign f's in the chat for
an ousted founder
you hate to see it but leaving open
faint behind was definitely a good thing
in hindsight it let jason get back to
what he loved doing most
building great software for gamers so he
set out to make a new game
this time he built a multiplayer online
battle arena for ipads
called hammer and chisel the basic idea
was to bring an experience like dota 2
or league of legends to mobile devices
and the initial response was quite good
he pitched the game at techcrunch
disrupt in 2014
and received lots of positive feedback
but true virality just wasn't there
and hammer and chisel fell short of
breakout success much like aurora fan
had six years earlier so once again
jason refocused on finding a problem
that all gamers struggled with and just
like with open faint
he landed on connecting socially while
gaming even though he had been focused
on mobile up to this point
jason and his team realized that the pc
would be a much easier
platform to target there were millions
of pc gamers who were open to trying new
software and building a communication
app for desktop pcs
would be easier than building something
that would run smoothly on a mobile
device while gaming so he started
building the first version of discord
with the goal of bringing great chat and
voice communication to gamers discord
was an almost immediate success
and lots of people credit the app's
improved design over competitors
as the main reason for discord's growth
but i think there's something more going
on here first off
discord doesn't just look different from
competitors like teamspeak or mumble
although we do need to take a second and
look at just how old those apps looked
at the time the discord launched
ridiculous the more important design
innovation here was the fact that
discord could run in a browser
so onboarding was extremely easy as long
as there was at least one person in a
group of gamers willing to quickly set
up a discord server everyone else could
just be invited with a simple link they
wouldn't need to install any program to
get up and running
something that all the other chat apps
required but that wasn't the real reason
people stuck around and switched to
discord permanently
see discord is all about building
authentic communities
a discord server might start with a few
friends or a specific topic in mind but
what really makes people keep opening
the discord app
is that sense of community and that's
jason's third key advantage
he's a great community builder this
comes from the fact that jason himself
is both a game developer and a gamer he
understands the impact that clear and
reliable voice communication
can have while playing a competitive
game he's an authentic member of the
gaming community
and you can feel that every time you
open discord but it doesn't stop there
when jason initially launched discord he
created a dedicated server just to help
new users
his entire team would be there to answer
any questions users had
and troubleshoot any issues that came up
he was also able to plant discord into
the right communities
by having friends post on specific
subreddits that were dedicated to
particular games
the final fantasy 14 subreddit was
particularly critical for discord's
growth in the early stage
since these players needed reliable
voice chat to communicate with their
friends in-game
by building a strong community of early
adopters and making discord easy to
share with friends
jason had finally created the viral
product that he never could as a game
developer
discord has been growing exponentially
since launch and i personally hope it
only gets more popular
jason is clearly a super talented
founder and someone we should all try
and emulate while building the next
generation of startups if you want to
chat about entrepreneurship
you can always just dm me on twitter and
please check out this recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it